fans and Stormtrooper costumes a hugely
secreted production and major shade from
the director of Gremlins the truth about
the Mandalorian might shock even the
most dedicated fans
when the first episode of the
Mandalorian hit Disney Plus in 2019 it
came with a very big reveal as well as
debuting a season-long plot line that
hadn't been mentioned in any Media or
trailers that preceded the series The
Mandalorian worked hard to ensure that
the existence of baby Yoda would be kept
a secret before the show's Premiere the
first season of course focuses on din
jarin a solitary Mandalorian who must
transport and protect the child a cute
creature that was quickly nicknamed baby
Yoda by fans series Creator John Favreau
decided to remain secretive about the
project after heeding the words of
Donald Glover who played Lando
Calrissian and solo a Star Wars story
Pharaoh explained to The Hollywood
Reporter Glover was saying that what
people really like now is to be
surprised because it doesn't happen that
much when Beyonce did an album she would
just put it online and everybody would
react to it just putting it out there
spurred a conversation that would become
more viral and bring more genuine
attention than any marketing Disney
Executives agreed with the approach and
kept all imagery at baby Yoda who was
eventually named grogu out of marketing
materials before the Mandalorian Pedro
Pascal was best known for his role on
Game of Thrones when producers first
approached him about playing the lead in
the Mandalorian he was apparently
reluctant in fact Pascal's close friend
Oscar Isaac who plays Poe Dameron in the
Star Wars sequel Trilogy was the one who
convinced him to take the role you're
welcome I convinced him to do it the
Jedi Ahsoka Tano who previously appeared
in multiple animated Star Wars projects
first appears in season 2 of the
Mandalorian for the live-action version
of the character producers hired Rosario
Dawson following a successful viewer
campaign she later told Vanity Fair it
first came from fans online someone
tweeted me and Van cast me I retweeted
back and I was like absolutely yes
please is he speaking
to you understand him someone on the
Star Wars publicity team saw the
exchange and sent the thread to producer
Dave filoni and the rest is history some
prestigious actors rounded out the cast
The Academy Award nominee Nick Nolte
appearing in an unforgettable role Carl
Weathers noted for his performance as
Apollo Creed and Rocky portrays grief
karga while former MMA star and American
Gladiator Gina Carano played Kara Dune
in the Show's first two seasons
critically acclaimed director Werner
Herzog stepped in as a pro-empire crime
Lord meanwhile Breaking Bad and Better
Call Saul Alum Giancarlo Esposito joined
the cast as ex-imperial officer moff
Gideon the creative team behind the
Mandalorian took inspiration from many
mid-20th Century works but they may have
borrowed a little too liberally from
some more recent pop culture entries Joe
Dante directed both Gremlins and
Gremlins to the new batch and he
believes that baby Yoda owes a lot to
Gizmo a furry little creature from his
films speaking to the San Francisco
Chronicle Dante said I think the
longevity of Gremlins is really key to
this one character who is essentially
like a baby which brings me of course to
the subject of baby Yoda who's
completely stolen and is just out and
out copied shamelessly I would think and
then there's American Dad which has been
running since 2005. in the episode
Persona assistance which first aired in
February 2019 the alien character Roger
develops a tumor which turns out to be a
strange sentient miniature version of
himself he names the monster which
becomes a recurring American Dad
character rogu his name's rogu
oh baby Yoda appears in the first
episode of the Mandalorian the name
grogu wasn't revealed until November
2020. basically it's undeniable that
both alien babies have nearly identical
names Kroger
season one of the Mandalorian wraps up
with a confrontation between the titular
Bounty Hunter and villain mop Gideon the
Mandalorian refused to return grogu to
his dangerous intended recipient and had
to contend with a veritable Army of
Stormtroopers a lot of anonymous foot
soldiers were required for the scene so
many that the production couldn't come
up with enough authentic stormtrooper
costumes according to comicbook.com the
makers of the Mandalorian took their
problem to Star Wars fans producers Dave
filoni and John Favreau called upon the
Chicago chapter of the 501st Legion a
devoted Star Wars fan and cosplay Club
its members appeared in the final two
episodes in the Mandalorian season 1
dressed in their privately owned film
quality stormtrooper costumes which they
purchased built and maintained which is
more than a little impressive the
Mandalorian is the first live-action
Star Wars series and it was the first
original series to debut on Disney plus
when the streamer launched in 2019.
according to Vanity Fair when Star Wars
production company lucasfilm decided to
pursue small screen storytelling
president Kathleen Kennedy commissioned
input from Iron Man director and known
Star Wars Enthusiast John Favreau
pharaoh to work after a single meeting
with Kennedy writing the first four
episodes of a show about a Mandalorian a
member of a race of helmet wearing
bounty hunters there could have been an
issue with overlap as lucasfilm was also
developing a movie about the best known
pre-existing Mandalorian in the Star
Wars saga Boba Fett however the problem
disappeared when director James Mangold
walked away from the Boba Fett movie to
make the fifth Indiana Jones film
however Dave filoni the creative force
behind several animated Star Wars
projects also wanted to make a TV show
about a Mandalorian Kennedy perfavro and
felony in a room and they got along so
well creatively that they combined their
ideas into a single project which became
the Mandalorian
as it's set during the storyline of the
original Star Wars saga the Mandalorian
is obviously inspired by classic science
fiction creators writers and producers
also pulled heavily from other sources
including Western's 20th century World
Cinema and Japanese manga star Pedro
Pascal told Entertainment Weekly the
Mandalorian is a mysterious lone
gunfighter in the outer reaches of the
Galaxy some might say he has
questionable moral character in line
with some of our Best Westerns the main
character's identity is shrouded in
secrecy which is not unlike the man with
no name and Sergio Leone's dollars
Trilogy starring Clint Eastwood series
producer and writer Dave filoni also
admitted to paying homage to Japanese
filmmaker Akira Kurosawa who influenced
Star Wars Creator George Lucas in an
interview with Slash film filoni
explained George's Mentor is Akira
Kurosawa so I've done a lot of study of
that I have a really small Akira
Kurosawa figure and he's in every
episode I've directed somewhere in the
set the Mandalorian also appears to
from Lone Wolf and Cub a long-running
manga series adapted into three films
like Mando and grogu's toiling around
the Galaxy Lone Wolf and Cub concerns
aronen who roams the Wilderness with a
child he protects when they run afoul of
powerful forces
the entire Star Wars Universe owes a
huge debt to George Lucas but the
Mandalorian has some specific ties to
the filmmaker for one the show is
heavily inspired by the first Star Wars
movie which Lucas directed especially
the episode's Cantina scene the
Mandalorian also uses technology
originally developed for the Star Wars
prequels but 20 plus years of technical
advancements added in Giancarlo Esposito
who portrays mop Gideon on the
Mandalorian revealed that Lucas's inputs
on the series goes even deeper speaking
to collider Esposito discussed the
creation of the show's costumes and sets
saying John Favreau was working with
George Lucas on this particular piece
and making it a piece that we can really
relate to now in our world that we're in
well John Favreau and his team use
practical effects as much as they could
to capture the handmade charm of the
original Star Wars digital Wizardry was
key to bringing the Exotic world of the
mandalorian's life it's worth noting
that Fabro has a fair amount of
experience working on primarily digital
movie sets as he's the person behind
Disney's live action The Lion King and
The Jungle Book remakes to create the
jaw-dropping special effects scene in
the Mandalorian the filmmakers utilize
the impressive volume technology which
can turn any Sound Stage into a 360
degree Panorama with the ability to
render detailed 3D environments in real
time the team was able to create digital
sets that felt truly immersive
discussing his approach to using new
technologies to create the show pavaro
told variety ultimately it's a human
factor that shapes our path into the
future and it's the people who are
innovating in those areas creating new
tools that are going to determine what
we inherit and what the future holds
at Star Wars celebration 2019 John
Favreau repeatedly emphasized that the
Mandalorian would be one giant love
letter to the original Star Wars Trilogy
and that tribute extends behind the
scenes as well pavro wants to make sure
the Mandalorian feels like our first
visit to that galaxy far far away and
that means embracing some old school
Film Production techniques naturally CGI
and special effects are necessary to
deliver the Mandalorian on a TV budget
but the crew is also using puppets
animatronics and special effects makeup
whenever possible for example Favreau
really wanted to make a model of the
razor Crest the mandalorian's ship to
use during production Industrial light
and Magics art staff were apparently so
excited about the idea that they didn't
just make a model unprompted they
reportedly went home and built a camera
rig in their garages recreating the
hardware that was used to make Star Wars
back in 1977 when the team that
dedicated it's unsurprising that the
Mandalorian became an instant hit with
viewers all over the world
foreign
[Music]